with John and Danny as we've seen before
with Cersei and Jaime there is a bit of
interfamilial closeness shall we say in
the show I'm very interested to find out
what Danny's and the expression on both
of their faces when they find out
they're actually quite closely related
is it gonna be one of those moments
where it's when I have no idea what's
gonna happen but I'm whatevs Danny gonna
fit kind of gonna feel when she finds
out that she's not actually entitled to
the seven kings of Westeros and fights
her nephew Jon Snow is supposed to be
the king of the Seven Kingdoms hey
everybody its charlie happy new year
surprisingly or unsurprisingly Game of
Thrones has officially confirmed what's
going on with season eight you know we
believe that we might not see it for a
long time but HBO really doesn't make
announcements unless they absolutely
have to we also got some roundabout
confirmation on which actors have
wrapped filming already so death
predictions because there are a number
of reasons why actors would wrap their
filming this early in their schedule so
I'll talk about the release date then
I'll talk about death predictions at the
end of the video sophie Turner seemingly
confirmed that they weren't going to
premiere till 2019 in an interview a
couple weeks ago now HBO is probably
making this official statement just to
acknowledge that usually they don't make
official statements like this till
somebody from the cast either leaks
something or some subtle confirmation of
something from behind the scenes starts
making the rounds through the press so
once it spreads like wildfire then
they're like okay fine we have to
actually say something about this
Entertainment Weekly is making it sound
like they definitely plan to premiere in
the spring just because they used to use
the spring as their premiere date every
single season so it makes sense that
they would go back to that for their
final season like it used to be April
every year but then they slowly started
sliding into May and then finally for
Season seven we got that big delay
they've been using Entertainment Weekly
for a lot of their big press releases
for the last couple of years mostly
because the publication doesn't run
spoilers or anything like that and they
just read things for Batum like if HBO
wants to get a message out they'll just
use II W as their finger puppets so they
reported last year that they were
mulling a release date like hey it might
be 2018 might be 2019 because the logic
was is that they just needed extra time
to figure the scripts out because like
Rick and Morty was a really good
example of a show that was delayed for a
full year because the writers just could
not get the scripts the way they wanted
them to so when it was announced that
they had all six scripts done
everybody's like what's the holdup now
it's like you're already filming later
in the year so it's winter in the places
that you're filming that was the reason
for the delay for season seven they just
had to wait till later in the year after
season six so that winter could
literally come to the places they were
filming like Episode one with the
Brotherhood was probably the best
example of that like you rewind to
season 4 when Arya and the Hound are
leaving that little homestead in it's
all green all this territory is a good
man the author makes nice to both be
dead come winter but cut the season 7 in
it's buried in snow this seems like a
good place to spend the night these
people don't want us here so those kind
of frustrating practical concerns
weren't an issue with season 8 like it
was already going to be winter when they
would start filming around the same time
that they started filming for season 7
so what might sound kind of weird but
the problem that they have with season 8
is is the way that they're filming is
different from the way they filmed
episodes before so they used to have
almost for film units running
simultaneously at times typically
there's two big film units and then like
a couple of their small ones depending
on what they need to do around other
parts of Westeros so in the early
seasons when you're over in the East
filming the Daenerys scenes that's the
dragon unit the wolf unit is the one
that does most of the stuff that you see
in Westeros when they got to season 3
the characters were so spread out that
they needed to add a third film unit
that was the Raven unit then really late
in the game around season six they added
the white Walker unit to film all that
brand white Walker stuff up at the wall
like when they invaded the three-eyed
Ravens tree so whereas in previous
seasons you had more scenes of the show
being shot simultaneously they can't do
that as much in the final season because
so many of the characters are in the
same place so like you have all this
stuff happening at King's Landing with
Cersei early in the season the golden
company you're on you have all the stuff
that's happening up at Winterfell so
really you have like two big film units
and maybe like some pickup shots with a
third film unit but for the most part
you just can't run that many scenes
simultaneously so it just physically
takes them
to get all the scenes that they need for
all the episodes the bigger concern is
also the scale of the productions for
each of the episodes so typically each
season you only have a couple big
battles like you have one big battle of
the Basterds a big hardhome during the
final season you'll have something of
that scale almost every episode
now they announce what the directors are
so I'll link that video at the end of
this because it implies where the
biggest battles will happen so whereas
you used to have like four assembly
lines it was okay if one of those
assembly lines took twice as long to get
one of the episodes out because it was
so big so there are fewer film units but
also on top of that the episodes take
twice as long as they normally would
even if you did have those extra bodies
to get the scenes out the light at the
end of the tunnel though is is that you
will be rewarded for your waiting with
six movies instead of six episodes of
Game of Thrones you know whereas like
the episodes have slowly gotten bigger
and bigger with each season it's massive
I mean it's by far the biggest
television show in the world at this
point you know we've got 700 crew
members and the cast of I think 583
named characters and then just Dothraki
number one through 3,000 and it really
is a cast of thousands at this point
we've shot and I think six different
countries now and every single day we
have at least two units running they've
been teasing that each of the season
eight episodes will be feature-length
and the interesting thing is they'll
continue filming principal photography
right up to the summer but miss and I
actually just wrapped all of her scenes
making it sound like she either dies
really quickly or she just takes off
after the first couple of episodes but I
don't think that she would leave two
nurses presents so theory crafting time
they're still filming all the episodes
right up to the summer why would miss
and I leave the show this early in their
filming schedule unless they're pulling
some shenanigans and she'll come back
for some inserts for like the last
couple of episodes it really does sound
like she dies in the first couple of
episodes but remember the third episode
is the first one that's being directed
by Miguel subhanak so that's probably
when the big Second Battle of Winterfell
is going to take place not to be
confused with the Battle of Winterfell
that's getting ready to happen in the
winds of winter book but they're also
trying to spin this like HBO and the e W
people are trying to spin this as giving
George our Martin extra time to finish
wins
winter-like oh you know it sucks that
we're not gonna get episodes for another
year but that'll give George that much
more time to get winds of winter out so
this certainly puts a damper on people
hoping to see winds of winter during
2018 there was a chance that he was even
gonna release two books I think I talked
about it during some of my episode
videos but obviously winds a winter is
the big book that he's finishing the
other one was fire in blood or at least
the first volume of fire and blood which
is like the complete history of the
Targaryen family it's not exactly his
Silmarillion but it's all this extra
material it just did not make the final
cut of the main novels but it's all
really good stuff so he's like all just
collected in a book and release it at
some later date so he has that waiting
to go we might see that before winds of
winter but don't worry even though
they're not gonna drop new episodes this
year they will have trailers teasers
images from behind the scenes they'll
still have all kinds of promotional
material that they'll drop so there will
be new Game of Thrones for us to pick
over and talk about so no worries there
but if there are any specific bonus
videos that you guys want me to do just
let me know in the comments below
there's a new round of the DVD giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video congratulations to the winner from
last week's video kevie and Kaz please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here to learn
about what's happening with each of the
episodes and click here to listen to sir
Davos talk about what's going on behind
the scenes thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight